hi there
it's uh 10 o'clock at night here i have
to admit that i'm a little tired
and um i'm gonna talk a little bit about
you know accumulating words
and the idea that um
you know it's not language learning is
not a sprint
and so i've never been that concerned
about how quickly i can learn something
unless for example
when i went to romania i had to
try to learn up romanian in two months
in order to go there and be able to
communicate but otherwise
i'm quite content to labor away
gradually accumulating words and
gradually accumulating a sense of the
language knowing that every little bit i
do even though i'm not aware of any
improvement
it is
accumulating it is
getting me closer to my eventual goal
and obviously the first 500 000 words of
the language you got to learn them and
you learn them typically in beginner
type texts that are very simple but
beyond that it really to my mind it
doesn't matter whether i learn the
word 1500 and the frequency list or the
word 5000 on the frequency list it
doesn't much matter to me because
eventually i'm going to have to learn
them all because eventually i want to
have a large vocabulary
so but i have to admit that it's easier
on the one hand it's easier if you have
texts with only 10 or 15 new words on
the other hand you're acquiring fewer
new words so
uh you know when i was learning russian
i didn't mind when i first i i got out
of the beginner text into tolstoy the
kreutzer sonata 50 new words i slugged
away it didn't bother me most people
perhaps don't have that amount of
patience
so right now i've got this uh podcast of
kim jung has
which in retrospect is probably too
difficult and a little too esoteric for
me a little too literary
uh not necessarily the vocabulary that
i'm looking for that i would want to use
there's one here he's talking about a
musician and treble and bass uh you know
and then he's talking about some medical
condition and a whole bunch of stuff
that's a little bit not so useful but i
don't mind
uh
and of course the fact is that i i like
listening to him
and i've paid now to have these uh
podcasts transcribed and i've got about
20 of them transcribed and we have them
in the uh
in our link library and i enjoy them and
all
but there's a lot of vocabulary that i
probably won't use right away
however still 70 80 of the vocabulary is
as as in all content as we know it
consists of the most common words so i'm
still gaining that sense of rhythm of
the language and so forth
now you have to kind of notice your
minor victories and a victory today as
i'm going through
saving now
so a sign that you're getting somewhere
is when you start to see
more and more and more and more words
that you know and fewer and fewer words
that you don't know
and this is quite apparent when you're
working at link because my normal op
you know method of operation is to go
through a text
looking up the words i don't know the
blue words linking them and these
podcasts of kim jong-un are between 30
and 50 minutes long so these are these
are not short lessons
and
as i'm going through them now
i find that as i you know because i can
just by hitting my
key here my entry key i go to the next
word the next word the next word and
more and more of the blue words i
already know them i don't need to look
them up they're variations of words that
i know that's why they're blue because
they're a different form of a word that
i've already learned
and so i'm now able to go through sort
of a 30 40 minute podcast the text of a
podcast saving words
uh in you know 15 20 minutes whereas it
used to take like an hour and a half
and when i first started linking korean
words i i had no
sense of whether the meaning was even
close to what i was looking for whereas
now the whole process has become easier
faster i feel i'm in control
and so while i'm not speaking so
wonderfully fluently
and i still have trouble when i try to
listen to the podcast to understand it
i know i'm progressing i know that i'm
chipping away at the goal and you know i
don't think it's unrealistic in in any
language to like my goal is to know 20
30 000 words that's where i want to get
to so i'm not fussed about whether it's
word 4000 in the frequency list or six
thousand in the frequency list
eventually i gotta learn twenty thousand
words and so i just labor away
hopefully with content that has some
appeal at some level and kim jong's
content does appeal in terms of the kind
of material that he's dealing with most
of the time reference to this novel to
some
american author or to some french author
and he talks about when he visited in
vancouver and and all of this stuff is
kind of intriguing to me even though
when he talks i don't understand it that
well but when i read through it i can
but the point i guess i want to make is
that uh even though i'm tired
beaten up here fighting my way through
these difficult texts i know that i'm
chipping away at this goal of eventually
having this large vocabulary in korean
uh i've only got 11 days to go
i don't think that i'll be speaking
appreciably better 10 or 11 days from
now than i speak today i am going to try
to line up
uh some tutor to speak to so that i will
have like an exit
conversation in korean and i'm gonna
promise to put up some subtitles just to
see where i end up
but i think the big achievement is that
i will have tremendously increased my
passive vocabulary and so that over time
these are sort of investments
in the language that will come back to
me as
the rest of my language skills catch up
so there you have it that's where we are
on day 79 bye for now